a un raid gaza sono super contento
perché ho due in news epiche da darvi
prove le do poi a fine video della fine
video perché questa settimana come la
settimana scorsa è stata piena di
stronzate quindi è giusto che vi faccio
vedere quanta ignoranza c'è stata negli
ultimi sette giorni quindi let's go è
perché c'è sempre sasha che deve delle
cozie no perché c'è una sedia vuota
state facendo ma che cazzo perché non
sono le cose di cattivo della giornata
ma non ha mai a casa al volo ma man
parole c'è pace ma che problemi hanno
oggi è giornata di me ma che cazzo cosa
state facile guerra è questa spiega io
non sto capendo cosa ha scatenato questa
cosa di fermarsi un attimo
va bene il perché attivato la scatola di
un fondo di istituto
la logica ma perché
ma cosa è successo
[Musica]
l'idroscalo praticamente come azzurri
posa chi non sa craniata cosa facevo le
views va bene lasciamo perdere i patiti
dei blog ci restano che tira craniata
alle cose siamo nel labirinto degli
specchi
comunque dobbiamo capire dov'è dove stai
andando posa ma direi siamo arrivati lì
la cisl ci siamo altri pacchi di latte
marca [ __ ] sta roba qua ragazzi l'ho
fatta una volta da piccolo e mi ricordo
favo tirato una craniata fortissima
contro il vetro è stato re perché qua
non vedi bene che cosa sei davanti nomi
chiamati dato una botta infatti è chiuso
porca eva lercio è però non direi chiuso
è quasi al passato qualcuno c'è un
setpoint all'aspetto io direi di andare
qua davanti che aspetta che devo mette
alla mano ha mai non guarda tanto sembra
infinito il corridoio è in food secondo
me stiamo andando bene c'è un altro
check point uno scotch ce l'abbiamo
fatta noi non è vero sto scherzando
questo metropolitane e siamo stati bravi
e per aver fatto un tentativo solo mai
così vai così i campioni incredibili che
champions ce l'abbiamo fatta sultano
perché fuori ci abbiamo messo un'ora e
mezza si faccia un saluto il cras grazie
sono riuscito a intrufolarsi dentro
questo stand che è completamente chiuso
non ci sono queste cose che galleggiano
sull'acqua che non so come si chiamano
ma ho sempre voluto provarle non sono
mai riuscito ovunque io sia che vedo
queste cose perché c'è una coda pazzesca
e non riesco mai a provarle yacht erano
inutilizzabili adesso però io mi ci
infilo dentro perché porca [ __ ] non è
possibile che non sia mai riuscito a
provarlo né questo dovrebbe andare che
figata
adesso che passa aereo adesso che passa
l'aereo sono tutti gli strati via
e stranissimo c'è una faccia bruttissima
gay degli store gol andando mentre su
uno stop ha lanciato qui mi stanno
chiamando non si sono forti che fra un
po tentazioni city qualcosa 10 no frate
frate e non posso uscire anche a trovare
la navigata delegato grafico famiglia la
bomba siamo venuti qua in questo parco
per fare una challenge che non vi posso
spoilerare questo coso qua che azzurri
in mano dalla scossa perché il simone
paciello cela alla caviglia in questo
istante
vai via vai via deve starmi lontano
tratto il devi stare lontano quindi vi
stare lontano cela la caviglia simone
voli dalla scossa violenta
[Risate]
[Musica]
cercavo
perché sono tante non possiamo dirlo ma
allora si salva buongiorno devo cambiare
l'olio la macchina indietro sul cofano
la pressione delle gomme attimo
velocemente anche grazie poi abbiamo
contro la nota oggi nel fioretto ma si
sbrighi e lento per bagagliaio
il catania è più bella un signore che
cosa vuole
tutto gratis oggi per me la facciano da
anni i soldi a scusa ha fatto la dentro
la nella porta rossa che ancora peggio
la nostra
[Musica]
il bersaglio è quello adesso facciamo un
tra yard pazzesco bersaglio della ti
vede come che ci provo f1 dai ris
ecco se stanno [ __ ] libellule
regalava qualcuno giuseppe a sera che se
stanno in groppa questo è porno vinse
chi le è vicino giuseppe fermo giuseppe
si sa dove sono
vabbè che va dai sei uno stronzo ti odio
perché quest'uomo una clava ma cos'è
questa roba ago quelle che stanno basta
giuseppe spingere dentro c'è anche
l'altro per onore benissimo qua non ho
usati falca garmin giusepe ti ammazzo ti
ammazzo da basse ma buttate fuori male
butti fuori o che schifo la cosa più
oscena che io abbia mai visto così come
tidona questa cosa questa cappa allora
devo dirlo in rosa e chic è già passato
via di moda tre anni fa ma dato che c'è
un t rex senza braccia poverino perché
senza abbraccio satira il cosa c'è nella
scatola misteriosa di polizia
cosa ci vuole la scatola abbiamo joypad
console subito malissimo le cuffie
giorgio giochi e lui non era scaturita
va bene quindi contare
a pezzo olivero ha conosciuto come la
cipolla carlo conti bianco drama the
shining di carlo corsa bellissima perché
sei vecchia scatola challenge di pesaro
insieme lo ha fatto la challenge dei
peperoncini e deve mangiare pane perché
sta morendo come è stata nato bellissima
dc rete impressioni vegas da un pezzo di
merda d'accordo ragazzi questo è ciò che
è successo più o meno durante la
settimana credo che ormai abbiate capito
che sta per uscire uscirà nei prossimi
mesi ovviamente la seconda stagione di
social face ski ha rinnovato la stagione
perché la prima stagione di social face
ha avuto un successo incredibile l'hanno
vista la mente in tantissimi e vi
ringrazio anche per questo perché c'è
stato un grandissimo lavoro dietro vi
posso assicurare ragazzi che questa
seconda stagione che abbiamo fatto è
pazzesco veramente la scuola scorsa in
confronto non era un cazzo spero con
tutto il cuore che gli piaccia non vi
posso dire una data d'uscita perché non
lo so non lo so ancora però ragazzi sarà
una bomba vera preparatevi perché sarà
veramente assurdo che sarà la prima news
che volevo dirvi mette ragazzi la
seconda news per chiudere il blog e che
da domani non è vero da dopodomani
scusate non è vero da dopo dopodomani
porca [ __ ] non solo i giorni io ai miei
partiremo alla volta del giappone sono
emozionatissimo non ve lo nascondo
perché il giappone è veramente la meta
dei miei sogni cioè io veramente guardo
un sacco di anime leggo man è da una
vita che ormai conosco un po di cultura
giapponese amo il loro modo di vivere il
loro stile di vita e quindi per me
andare in giappone è un viaggio
incredibile vale molto di più di un
viaggio in america ragazzi voi non avete
idea di quanto io sia contento cercherò
di farvi vedere un po di giappone
attraverso i miei occhi perché
ovviamente cercherò di bloccare tutto
quanto o almeno tutto il possibile prima
che sasha non mi scassi qualcosa tipo la
videocamera e niente ragazzi spero che
vi sia piaciuto cose
l'argomento è un mi piace anche a pace
di facebook e come tale descrizione per
fischiati ci mettiamo proseguito e
ragazzi